[Música]
economía directo américa de france 24
nuevamente daniela pues sin duda
obviamente la economía por estos tiempos
más protagonistas que nunca y eso con la
noticia del día no también el valor del
euro y el dólar están a punto de
encontrarse finalmente digamos ya
estando par par par porque será un
poquito dispares estar en pocos sentimos
de lograrlo y es que el euro está en su
nivel más bajo desde julio de 2002 hace
varios días en ese momento la brecha
entre las dos monedas más importantes
del mundo también favorecía al euro y es
que la moneda común de 19 países
europeos se ha depreciado más del 12 por
ciento en lo corrido del año y ahora
está a unos cuantos sentimos como le
decía de cotizarse al mismo precio que
el dólar a que se este comportamiento de
el dólar continúa impulsando las
expectativas de que la reserva federal
suba los tipos de interés más rápido y
en mayor medida que sus pares pero por
el lado europeo la depreciación de la
moneda tiene que ver con la preocupación
de que la crisis energética lleve a la
región a una recesión tras el cierre
temporal también del mayor caso porque
lleva gas ruso a alemania el north
stream o no además la comisión europea
anunció que volverá a recortar su
pronóstico de crecimiento anual para
este año por segunda vez danny y croacia
hablando del euro ahora usará esta
moneda pues dios después de obtener las
respectivas autorizaciones de la unión
europea este país se va a convertir en
el vigésimo en ingresar a la zona euro y
usar la moneda común a partir del
primero de enero de 2023 ahora veamos la
moneda que aparece en pantalla es la
moneda nacional que croacia va a
abandonar se llama cuna y ahora los
ciudadanos que lleguen del resto de la
zona euro no tendrán que cambiar su
efectivo la entrada al euro no vull
también tiene recompensas políticas
porque la moneda compartida es el
proyecto más ambicioso de europa para
integrar a sus estados nacionales y les
dan de hecho un asiento en las
principales mesas de toma de decisiones
esta es también la primera expansión del
bloque monetario en casi una década
después de que lituania aportará o
adoptará mejor el euro en 2015 bueno y
seguimos también con otra noticia esto
ha sido mejor dicho una novela la acción
de tus desde desplomó después de que se
arrepintiera de comprarla y veremos
cuánto cae el día de hoy o cuánto sube
uno nunca lo sabe pero lo que sí es
cierto es que el lunes cayó casi un 12
por ciento en el primer día bursátil
después de que el pasado viernes y los
que decidiera retirarse del negocio de
compra de la compañía por unos 44 mil
millones de dólares la razón sin duda es
económica aunque el multimillonario ha
dicho que es porque no le han dado
información verídica sobre cuentas
falsas ahora veamos la evolución de la
acción el 13 de abril cuando se cerró el
trato la acción de twitter costaba casi
46 dólares y el magnate ofreció 54,2 por
título hoy en día twitter cotiza por
debajo de los 33 dólares es decir que el
precio de la empresa ha perdido casi una
tercera parte desde que se pactó la
compra y también ha retrocedido un 14
por ciento si se compara con lo que
estaba ofreciendo en ese momento el
dueño de texas que viene ahora de las
partes raúl se preparan para una batalla
legal sin duda después de que twitter
prometiera defenderse más que debe pagar
una multa de mil millones de dólares por
no haber cumplido el trato pero utilizar
no solamente quiere eso también quiere
que se complete la transacción y habrá
que ver también cómo reaccionan los
accionistas al hecho de que al final la
empresa va a quedar en manos
probablemente de alguien que no la
quiere comprar un experto explica lo que
se espera
no no hay ganadores en términos de moss
en twitter quiero decir sólo para ser
claros todos son perdedores en términos
de cómo se desarrolló el negocio en
última instancia el siguiente paso de
twitter será demandar formalmente ambos
en la corte de delaware obviamente tú
eres estar reuniendo a su equipo legal y
nos tiene el sutil así que luego esto se
va a desarrollar prolongadamente en una
larga batalla que llevará muchos meses
posiblemente hasta bien entrado 2023 y
volviendo al tema también del dólar el
euro y cómo se ha manejado todo esto
cómo están los mercados o las acciones
de estados unidos abrieron mixtas hace
pocos minutos con los ojos del mercado
puestos sobre el dato de inflación que
se conocerá esta semana mientras que las
bolsas europeas avanzan con descensos en
la jornada a medida que el euro sigue
perdiendo valor frente al dólar en asia
los mercados cerraron con pérdidas
pronunciadas en particular hong kong en
donde las autoridades anunciaron que
están considerando implementar un
sistema de código de salud o electrónico
esto para restringir los movimientos de
personas contagiadas con kobe 19 y algo
similar también a lo que ya existe en
china continental danny como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica mañana por
supuesto con más nos vemos electa hasta
parís